you crazy mother
[Applause]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so you've downloaded Dauntless and
you're enjoying it but you're still a
little unsure about a few things well I
thought I put this little list together
to help a casual Slayer get the best out
of their time on the hunt there are
links in the description if you want to
skip any sections you already know about
and no bouncing on goats in Ramsgate is
not a tip but it's damn fun anyway let's
do this first we're starting with the
biggest thing to know let's break down
those numbers white numbers blue numbers
red numbers
yellow numbers what the heck do they
represent and which one do we want the
most to quickly answer that we want to
be eating yellow numbers constantly this
will reap the best rewards and make you
a valued member of the hunt
yellow damage is part damage it could be
a leg it could be a tail the horn may be
any area of the behemoth which isn't its
center car its torso for example a
subtle one we can target the magma pods
on the side of the Shahrukh keep hitting
it until those yellow numbers become
white and now he's unable to use that
area of his attack I have a bigger point
about combat tactics so let's not dwell
here for too long
so keep in mind yellow damage is our
Holy Grail when a part becomes white
move on to another limb of that behemoth
let's make sure we understand those
white numbers though each behemoth has a
hidden health pool we cannot see to take
it down we are looking for white damaged
numbers nothing else will kill that
beast but Adam you just said we need to
hit yellow numbers yeah you're right
here's why the confusing elements we all
need to understand is that all other
damage types red blue yellow are all
contributing to killing the behemoth the
white number is hidden when those
numbers pop up but don't worry if there
are no mods on your equipment that
yellow number is exactly the same as it
would be if it were there in white I
believe they've taken them away so the
screen isn't cluttered with numbers
although because of fortnight and
Borderlands I really like seeing those
numbers pop up anyway here's an
imaginary health call for this behemoth
this strike is yellow which Inge's that
area but also takes down the overall
health of the beast it
isn't exactly the same with red and blue
damage numbers so let's break those down
next the blue and red numbers indicate
damage modifiers available in the
battlefield the red numbers have wound
damage and the blue are stagger damage
to understand these we need to quickly
go through weapon types the best way to
do this is to compare the War Pike to
the hammer my favorite weapons in
dogless with similar abilities but both
have extremely different uses on the
battlefield basically the war Pike is a
bladed weapon and the hammer is
therefore blunt force trauma the pike
has the ability to quickly open wounds
on a behemoths body part seen by these
little gashes if we see one and hit it
again we will get red numbers instead of
yellow red numbers are wound damage
these are here to speed up the crippling
of one area of the behemoth the best way
to look at this is using the tail
opening wound will make it easier and
far far quicker to cut off the behemoths
tail each weapon class has damage buffs
when you see red numbers all but
piercing weapons but that's a discussion
for another time understanding the
difference between a piercing stab and
the slushing blow let's not go too deep
right now let's just get the
fundamentals in place and finally the
blue numbers this is stagger damage see
this as the balance of the behemoth
causing it to trip and fall so we can
beat the crap out of it for a few
seconds the hammer is the king of
staggers although the sword the axe
chain blades have this skill just to a
lesser degree the hammer is the best
though as the blue numbers can also be
high white numbers - but remember
they're hidden away ok but they are
there so the hammer can't stagger and
damage simultaneously this skill is
reduced in other weapons and if you're
unsure when the behemoth is about to
stagger look for the bubbles above its
head these indicate the behemoth is
groggy like a grandma on the Christmas
sherry one more hit and she's falling
over or maybe that's just it's my granny
so there we have it damage types
complete white base health yellow is a
holy grail we are looking to find red
extra damage to those parts and blue is
my grandma falling over drunk strange
but hopefully that helps and there's a
kicker to this entire section when you
reach the endgame well in fact when you
reach mid game mods can change all these
stats and add stagger damage or slash
damage to any weapon give an ultimate
control over to our Slayers oh the next
point leads in perfectly
reshaping a fight you may not realize
but you can [ __ ] areas of a behemoth
which will change how they fight some
make your day out much easier but others
will cause the behemoths to act more
aggressively or move differently which
in turn causes you additional issues
we've already said about disabling the
magma pods on the side of the chair Rock
but on top of that we can mane behemoths
by crippling legs causing them to walk
around slowly limping
some even limp so much you feel sorry
for them if there's a behemoth using
their tail to attack cut that tail off
we can completely stop those worrisome
attacks on the flip side though cutting
off that tail may result in a new
animation taking its place getting
drop-kicked
he's not fun try out different tactics
I'm working on a video showcasing all
hidden behemoth moves and the best parts
to take out you know
right let's look at the hood so the
percentage meter in the top corner it's
confusing shizzle isn't it it's
basically there to add tension to the
hunt if the meter reaches 100% we can no
longer revive teammates this is why you
shouldn't use yourself revives in the
early part of the fights stay grounded
and get picked up not only do you save
yourself res but the danger meter drops
a few percent when you are revived this
can lead to tactical deaths to prevent
the beast from going on full
mother-in-law mode here's a cool way of
tricking that percentage meter double
reviving when a teammate falls in battle
have two friends revive him at the same
time each time the animation completes
the danger meter drops but here's what's
awesome it will drop again when the
second person completes that animation
trick the system I'm not sure if this is
here forever so in the meantime take
advantage of it double revive as a
passing point did you know that my
creator code atom ro ad am a ru works in
dauntless - it would be pretty cool if
you used it but no pressure I'm going to
throw in now a few really quick tips if
you didn't pick them up from the start
of your journey you may not be having
the best of times on the hunt firstly
put away your goddamn weapon when you
are not using it running with the weapon
out and naya lates your stamina bar so
put it away dude
same goes for within a fight if you are
expecting a certain move weapons down
and run to evade as the fights become
longer and more drawn out knowing when
to battle and knowing when to run for
your life are pivotal moments another
one which we are shown in the opening
battle is rolling to evade the problem
is we instinctively roll away from
danger it's what we do in real life but
here in dauntless you need to be well
just that dauntless fearless brave
valiant any more synonyms don't think of
anything anyway roll in two attacks I
know it seems suicidal but it's not I've
spoken about this in my introduction
video but let's quickly go over a frames
in dauntless while strolling or evading
we have a few milliseconds
which we are invincible indestructible
invulnerable meaning that behemoth
whatever he does cannot hurt us this is
the biggest weapon in your arsenal
rolling through attacks rolling into
danger rolling towards the thing you
should be running from by doing so you
can be up close and personal in the
perfect position once the behemoth has
finished their attack those inventory
frames are what makes this game unique
well that's and bouncing on goats yeah I
need stop doing that but yes my point is
roll towards danger let's talk about
pooping if this the first time you've
heard that you probably want to strike
me for inappropriate content but let's
talk about pooping behemoths it's really
a stagger attack but let's give it its
own section all the same booping' is
interrupting a behemoth when they are
unbalanced usually when they are mid
attack in one of those over-the-top
moments we can take out our weapon and
when the Ember main charges shriek flies
towards you
OOP Bhangarh when rolling oh you you get
the idea
pooping or interrupting attacks is a
great way to cause massive damage when
the creature hits the ground my
preference is to boot with the hammer or
the wall pike
but since the console release our
weapons can perform interrupts some more
successful than others another way to
Boop an enemy is to hit back their
projectiles I'm still learning how this
affects each behemoth but if you have
the timing right hit those projectiles
back where they came and hopefully in
the moment my final point is one about
working with others when you reach mid
game and need specific body parts broken
let people know what you need
optimize your gameplay with coordination
I've noticed in public lobbies the mics
aren't used very often so the next best
thing is to keep an eye on your
teammates if someone is constantly
whacking away on the tail they probably
need that part for an armour set so go
help them out if we pay things forward
like this will improve another person's
experience of Dauntless and hopefully
they will reciprocate if not to you then
to someone else in their mix
hunt these games are community games we
need one another for it to survive
anyway I'm going all emotional so let's
call it there that was ten quick tips to
make you a better Slayer in dauntless if
you stayed this long into the video
please take my thanks you are a legend
to me nobody stays this long write in
the comments below like a boss and I'll
find you and give you some love I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade
this is dauntless and I'll see you next
time
[Music]